That's not me
god you're so good pranked you so hard
please don't click off hi guys welcome
to Friday hurry a diary video montage
should look back at my week I didn't
film a lot of things because this was a
relatively slower week so stick around
through the very end I'm gonna do a
really quick ugly sweater tutorial a lot
of people have ugly sweater parties
around this time of year and I'll show
you a really quick simple easy way that
you can make an ugly sweater for an
event with everything that you probably
have on hand you don't have to buy
anything and it's really let's look back
on my week good morning we made it to
the venue in Tempe it's a Tempe improv
look let's look at some of the people
that have been here look okay's photos
just having fun having fun talking about
their pain having fun talking about pain
can't wait we bring riders to our show
meaning like a list of things that we
need for the show prop lies and tech
wise and just a list of things that
personally we would love to have like
waters and teas and just a whole tray of
beers and vodka and mixers and what time
is it made the treating is very
wonderfully here Thank You Tempe sorry
Tempe audience okay we got done our
Tempe show at the final show this might
get weird y'all and the final show of
2014 which was it was so fun and weird
to end the tour with a show on a Sunday
at 3:00 p.m. even weirder still the show
that came into the venue after us was
Dana Carvey my dad would his pants
knowing that
I left three of my books in the dressing
room with a note today in a Crabby so
we'll see if he takes them now I'm at
the hotel for a couple hours my flight
is until later tonight so I'm just gonna
relax I'm gonna go through letters and
all the wonderful goddamn you guys gave
us stuff and one of the craziest gifts
that I think mamrie and I have ever
gotten is this girl may her friend whom
I guess makes stuffed animals it goes in
all of the spots and all every like oh
all of its my dog as a stuffed animal
like rendered exactly and she also made
one from a Marie of beans
so Tempe Arizona in general you might
have been the weirdest of the weirds and
in the most wonderful way so thank you
for a really great tour all of the city
so he went to
then do security line a better
experience oh hello I made it back to
New York City from Tempe that's where I
was Tempe
it's Monday I've had a very non
productive day which is great
because I flew in this morning and I got
a chance to just relax
and I'm a little sick post this might
get weird y'all so it was nice to just
chill I washed my hair that's a great
sign that I'm caring about myself and
making myself a better person really
striving taking risks putting myself out
there
- so 2014 got it end strong here's what
I'm really excited about tomorrow
morning Tuesday morning by the time
you've watched this little this will
have already happened but I'm gonna be
on The Today Show with Kathy and Hoda
it's finally hitting my brain and I'm
freaking out it's live television with
two women that are just like for those
of you that don't have the Today Show
Kathy and Hoda are basically like if
they I feel like it's the closest thing
to if they gave mamrie and I a morning
talk show they drink wine at 11:00 a.m.
and it's my it's I'm just I'm so excited
now here's the thing no yep that's great
we don't give a rip
you got a catchphrase you gotta make
merch now that's how YouTube work
good evening it's Tuesday night what a
day it's been this morning I did the
Today Show with Kathie and Hoda and it
was it was really cool it's a whirlwind
those morning shows they do so much in
so little time and there's so many
people involved and it's just this
insane waltz dance of seemingly chaos
but actual organization that's happening
but I will say that Kathie and Hoda one
beautiful in person too so nice it was
really great I had a really great time
then it rained in New York all day so I
didn't do too much other than catch up
on YouTube videos send emails business
business put this headband on that took
a lot of time now about to edit my video
for Wednesday then I'm actually pretty
excited about if I can edit it the way I
see it in my brain there's the update
good job you me not you guys I mean good
job you four beep you're still here
good job hello it is Wednesday and I am
just getting work done I don't have a
ton of stuff to do today so I'm getting
work done and to motivate myself to get
work done I've made myself a workstation
look help and cute this is all
motivating things he isn't very proud of
it you know just doing that made me feel
like I got work done so I can take a
break
yeah cool hair hey guys this has been a
seemingly uneventful week in terms of
what I've been doing in videos for the
past like 48 hours I've just been
sitting on my computer on Etsy buying
Christmas present really close to buying
a homemade fairy garden house kit where
you build your own fairy house in a
garden not as a gift for anyone just for
me because I was in just such a state of
whimsy because that's what she does to
you anyway it's Thursday and I just got
some really amazing amazing news and I
can't tell you right now but excuse me I
am drinking some champagne to celebrate
because it's really really exciting and
I don't think I will be able to tell you
until next week I know I know I
shouldn't even be saying this if I can't
tell you right now but I'm really really
excited I just wanted to share that
emotion with you
okay so later in the night and I just
want to let you know I got so excited
about the news I got earlier that I just
kind of curled my hair I don't have
anywhere to go
tonight or anything to do in fact my
only thing to do is to just drink some
wine and champagne by myself but I
curled my hair because
welcome to a very quick and easy
ugly-sweater tutorial if you don't have
time to go shopping to get supplies to
create a very elaborate ugly sweater
here's a really simple easy way to make
one all you need is any sweater you
already have tape a writing utensil and
some paper take the paper and your pen
turned out by writing this sweater is
huzzah then we're going to tape that to
the front top center of your sweater
this way also you get to use the sweater
as a regular sweater after whatever
seemingly fun but probably not as fun as
you hoped it would be party you go to
yay then we're gonna take the rest of
our paper and just write some really non
complimentary things on it and then
you're done there you go
whoa that's one ugly sweater you're
welcome
well that's it that's everything that
happened this week hopefully you enjoyed
that quick tutorial and what are the
things happen this week oh the podcast
not too deep is on itunes best of 2014
the podcasts it's so cool so if you
haven't been listening to the full
episodes of not too deep on iTunes or
SoundCloud please go do that it's been
chosen as something that is of a decent
quality you won't waste your time what
else is happening I have to do more
Christmas shopping that's not that
exciting and hmm I don't know oh that's
the end the tree look
yeah it's just thrilling really just
real those trees
I probably show self-conscious compared
to